Che cos'è
Non mi sembra una scatola di biscotti
Buongiorno Anita
[Musica]
Meno male è stato solo un brutto sogno
vediamo dove devo andare
Wow
con il mio spazzolino si stava davanti i
denti Ah ma che stai dicendo è andato
via la lupo Mannara No no Mi devi
credere Stavo in bagno Vai a controllare
zitta adesso ma come finire una partita
Ti sto dicendo che c'è la lupa lì Uffa
mi hai fatto sfracellare di nuovo Non
c'è nessuna Lupa e vai a controllare
Vedilo con i tuoi occhi vediamo
proprio qua Cioè era qua ecco te l'ho
detto non c'è nessuno ma no vedi cioè
nel mio il mio dentifricio qua stavo
utilizzando il mio spazzolino ma non c'è
nessuno guarda ci sei solo tu forse ti
sei visto tu allo specchio Ti sei
spaventato come se ti dico che c'era la
lupa forse non ti sei ancora svegliato
da stamattina Io torno a finire la mia
partita Ciao Forse aveva ragione Anita
magari era solo un brutto sogno Certo
però era così realistico Magari la
prossima volta provo a darmi un
pizzicotto e magari mi sveglio vado ad
annaffiare i fiori adesso
[Musica]
dei fiori Grazie ma ma quindi non è un
sogno aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
Questa volta mi sono ricordato un
pizzicotto per vedere se sto sognando
Ahia
mi hai spostato la mandibola
sto quindi non sto sognando mamma mamma
che ci fai ancora qui perché mi hai dato
questi fiori che cosa vuoi
ha detto che mi hai dato questi fiori
perché mi ama
no Luca Dai lasciami in pace lasciami in
pace
[Musica]
hai scelto i fiori meno belli del
giardino Però grazie lo stesso prego
i fiori
brutti bello l'ho trovato qua fuori Mi
sono anche andato un pizzicotto per
vedere se si sono sveglia oppure no ma
in realtà lei è qua fuori Mi hai seguito
mi sono trovato tipo
i fiori Ancora con questa storia della
Lupa Se non c'è nessuno te lo stai
immaginando No no Lei era proprio qua
fuori Guarda Andiamo a vedere vediamo se
c'è davvero questa luppa
attenta però
i fiori
e non c'è traccia di Luca Magari è
andata qui da qualche parte si è
nascosta e Aiutami però Ma no non c'è
nessuno tu sei rimasto troppo scioccato
dalla scorsa volta Avete visto gli
scorsi episodi in cui la lupara
sbaciucchiato Vitale se non li avete
visti andate a vederli dopo questo video
e quindi dopo che sono successe quelle
cose Tu ora la immagini Ovunque ti
sembra di vederla dappertutto ma in
realtà se n'è andata via sì proprio così
io la vedo dappertutto ma perché lì c'è
davvero
[Musica]
ma questo tu lo dici perché non hai mai
baciato una Lupa non hai mai sentito il
suo alito di ferro di ferro Sì il ferro
zolfo tipo Beh per fortuna non mi è mai
capitato Comunque io ora devo continuare
la mia partita Ciao
ma come Anita continua a non credermi
devo riuscire a convincerla in qualche
modo
Uffa Ma perché Anita non mi crede dovrei
trovare qualche indizio per farle capire
che la lupa è stata qua vediamo se
magari ha lasciato qualche pelo qui per
terra
non sembra esserci
[Musica]
E cosa ci fai qui
No basta basta basta basta basta no no
no no
aspetta aspetta Facciamo così facciamo
così io me ne vado e poi tu puoi fare
quello che vuoi vado
a chiamare
Che cosa c'è nascosto là dietro
cuore cuore
io tu pure io tu quale io tu
tu
Sei una mano che ti sboccia
cosa stai facendo
Che cos'è
Non mi sembra una scatola di biscotti
devo avere paura non devo avere paura Io
sto già avendo un sacco di paura No
guarda io accetto solo scatole di
biscotti in regalo e questa Che cos'è il
cioccolatini per caso
[Musica]
lo devo aprire io devo aprire io ok L'ho
preso
ma devo aprirlo
ma di cioccolato
veramente
[Musica]
Ma che cosa stai dicendo
questo vuol dire che vuoi sposarmi
[Applauso]
No Aspetta Devi capire una cosa io
ammonita Eh
non posso la mia fidanzata
[Applauso]
non potevo porta è il mio cuore di Anita
Ah ah ah
vedi lupo io non potrò mai amarti è il
mio cuore batte per la vita
[Musica]
Oh no si è arrabbiata tantissimo questa
volta le ho proprio spezzato il cuore
ma non posso sposarmi con la lupa Eh
devo andare ad avvisare Anita adesso e
ora credo proprio che mi creda visto che
ho l'anello prima di tornare a giocare
vado a prendere un albicocca Ehi Ma voi
avete lasciato un mi piace Mi raccomando
cliccate mi piace qua sotto e se volete
entrare a far parte del nostro team
iscrivetevi e attivate la campanella e
ora andiamo a prendere una buonissima
albicocca
[Musica]
Eccolo qua il mio albero di albicocco
devo prendere l'albicocca più grande che
sarà più dolce Magari questa va beh no
mi è caduta
Vabbè questa andrà bene
[Musica]
era buona
e la prossima stage
[Musica]
Vitale vecchia
ora devo finire questo livello
[Musica]
Vitale
che stai facendo
Ah
ho capito Vuoi farmi una sorpresa
hai mal di gola Forse e farli in modo un
po' strano
Ok ma dimmi che cos'è questa sorpresa mi
hai comprato un regalo qualcosa
Oh che bello Non vedo l'ora di vedere
cosa mi hai comprato
una torta magari ok Devo seguirmi quindi
va bene
Ok ti spiego Stiamo andando fuori forse
ma è sicura che non è uno scherzo no no
ok Vediamo
C'è una torta con la panna magari
[Musica]
posso toglierla